What should any country do to increase the money supply of its currency?
It could print paper currency at its discretion
Well, what is the situation with regard to cryptocurrencies
that are virtual currencies that are just codes and do not have a tangible texture
as mentioned in the previous episodes?
In answering this question, we will focus today on Bitcoin specifically
as the most famous, oldest and most valuable cryptocurrency
in the world today as the leader of digital currencies.
How are the new bitcoins coming into existence?
How are bitcoins [that never existed before] being created?
Do they come out of nowhere, or there must be a complicated process behind its creation?
This is what we will try to understand together in today's episode
I'm Ashraf Ibrahim, and this is our sixth episode of our new series on cryptocurrency "Crypto Economic Informant".
Well guys, there is only one way to create new bitcoins
and it is meticulously drawn and regulated by the inventor of bitcoin
Satoshi Nakamoto. This process is called mining. We will talk about it in detail later.
But in a nutshell and simply, as we mentioned before,
there is the so-called Blockchain which is a distributed database
in which data or transactions are stored accurately and securely in the form of blocks
When the block is filled with a number of transactions, it is closed and joined to the previous block chain, and so on.
Who makes sure that bitcoin transactions are correct before putting them into a new blockchain?
It is the miners who do the mining operations
They even compete with each other, which one is faster in confirming transactions
The competition itself depends on the mining power of each miner
or strength and the number of mining devices he / she has, which we will talk about in detail in the next episodes
Ok, so what do they get in return? What makes a person use very expensive mining equipment
that consumes a high amount of energy in order to verify transactions
and then put it in a block and include it in the blockchain?
They do this to win two things:
First, the biggest and most important reward
the block mining reward, which is new bitcoins. Second, the fees on transactions
I will be discussing them separately  in another episode.
So let us focus today on the reward of block mining
Any miner who can prepare a new block and include it in the block chain
takes a certain number of bitcoins as a reward
That is why they call it block rewards and it is the only way to extract bitcoins.
However, according to Satoshi Nakamoto's Bitcoin protocol,
the coin was designed to be available only in a limited amount, 21 million bitcoins
He wanted the currency to be scarce so that inflation would not occur and the value
of the currency would decrease accordingly. Because as you know, any increase in the number or supply
of any commodity reduces its value accordingly.
The same applies to traditional currencies as well.
When the central bank of any country increases the supply of its local currency;
The value of this currency will decrease and remain worthless
Therefore, Satoshi refused to offer the coin randomly,
preferring to have only 21 million bitcoins around the world first and foremost.
So, how will those 21 million bitcoins come to existence?
As we said a little while ago through mining.
Every miner who makes a new block and joins it to the blockchain
takes a number of bitcoins as a reward.
Here comes a crucial point: According to the white paper published by Satoshi Nakamoto in 2008
which is the constitution of Bitcoin as we said before.
The block reward size will be halved after every 210,000 blocks are generated.
This number of blocks takes approximately 4 years to be mined
because there is a new block that is being mined every 10 minutes, as we explained before.
So, we can simply say that 144 blocks or blocks are mined per day
When bitcoin mining began in January 2009,
a miner would take a reward of 50 bitcoins for every block mined.
Do you remember the formation block, The first block, the zero block?
We said that Satoshi took a reward of 50 bitcoin that time.
They were the first 50 bitcoins to come to existence.
He took 50 bitcoins in the second block and the same in the third block, ...
and so in all the blocks that were included in the blockchain, up to the number 210 thousand,
which was mined in 2012, and at that time the number of bitcoins reached 10,500,000.
Then the reward was halved and became 25 bitcoins
for each block that was mined reaching the number 420 thousand
that was mined in 2016
and at that time the number of bitcoins reached 15,750,000.
After that, the reward was halved to 12.5 bitcoins for each block that is mined,
up to the 630 thousand block that was mined in May 2020,
when the number of bitcoins reached 18,375,000.
After that, the reward was halved to 6.25 bitcoins
for each block mined in the past two years, or will be mined
to reach block number 840 thousand, which will be mined in May 2024, God willing.
This means that miners mining right now at that moment in 2022
are taking a 6.25 Bitcoin block reward for every block they include to the block chain.
On the day this episode was written, the number of bitcoins all over the world
reached 19,060,000 bitcoins and a little change.
This represents about 90% of the total number of bitcoins planned to be mined,
which is 21 million bitcoins, as aforementioned.
So, are you preplixed with all these numbers?
I will summarize it for you as follows,
every 4 years the block reward is halved,
and this will continue for the month of May 2140, God willing.
At that time, the entire 21 million bitcoins will be extracted,
which is the maximum number of bitcoins, and after that, the rewards for mining any block will be zero.
You might be asking what the miners will gain in return?
What is left for them whenever the rewards are zero? What is the incentive for them to continue mining?
They will have the transaction fees that we mentioned quickly at the beginning of the episode,
and as said, we will be discussing it in a separate episode, God willing.
This was a review on the run about the block reward for miners and its system.
In the next episodes of our series "Crypto Economic Informant" we will continue, God willing,
to clarify this interesting world, so stay tuned.
Don't miss any episode of the series to fully understand the basics of the cryptocurrency world
In the end, I want to say that this episode is sponsored by ‘Rain’ application,
which is the first platform licensed by the Central Bank of Bahrain to trade cryptocurrency
Do NOT forget to subscribe to the channel and activate the bell
to be notified about all our coming episodes, see you soon, God willing,
in the sixth episode of the series.Goodbye